der Machthunger Moskaus im Baltikum
kennt man ihn ganz
genau es gibt nur einen Feind und das
ist Russland es ist also naiv zu glauben
dass Russland weit weg
ist das Baltikum erst seit gut 30 Jahren
unabhängig von der
Sowjetunion viele hier blicken auf
Russland den ehemaligen Besatzer wieder
besonders
argwöhnisch wir wären bereit mit der
Waffe in der Hand an die Front zu gehen
den Feind zu bekämpfen und die Heimat zu
verteidigen ihre Freiheit an ihrer
Ostsee wollen die Balten nie wieder
verlieren Ich habe vor gar nichts Angst
wenn die Ukrainer die Russen schlagen
können dann könnten wir das auch lass
die nur kommen alles wird
gut ich treffe Menschen in Estland
Lettland und litaauen
alle drei Länder mit direkter Grenze zu
Russland und ich erlebe wie plötzlich
wieder düstere Erinnerungen hochkommen
in die Gegenwart der
[Musik]
Balken
auf dem Weg zur estnischen Insel Huma
ursprüngliche Natur zu Sowjetzeiten aber
gesperrt für Besucher weil strategisch
so wichtig einsour in den Nordwesten aus
Moskauer Sicht auf humuma ein Ort an dem
die Sowjetzeit gebalt sichtbar ist das
Militärmuseum mit alten denkmäln die man
seit letztem Jahr abgebaut und hier
verstaut hat
die Sowjetunion hat Estland 1940 besetzt
also müssen wir immer noch den Truppen
die uns besetzt hatten die Ehre erweisen
ich denke nein es war jetzt echt an der
Zeit seit Kriegsbeginn in der Ukraine
lässt Estland die sowjetmonumente aus
dem öffentlichen Raum verschwinden
Moskau das ewige gefühlte Problem der
Balten mehr den
[Musik]
je Finnland Schweden und wir sind an der
Ostsee mit Polen Deutschland Dänemark
sie alle sind Freunde es gibt nur einen
Feind und das ist Russland es ist also
naiv zu glauben dass Russland weit weg
ist wegen des Kriegs in der Ukraine
haben sie einen Raum neu eingerichtet
mit krassen
Elementen das ist ein echtes Andenken
aus der bachmutreion das sind Teile
einer Uniform und der Helm von einem
getöteten russischen
Soldaten
eine Uniform als Warnung vor der alten
Besatzungsmacht und ihrem neuen
Krieg Krieg ist eine sehr schreckliche
Sache da gibt es nichts Romantisches
nichts Schönes nichts
ruhmreiches es ist ein höllisches Gefühl
wenn man sowas trägt allein dieser Teil
der Ausrüstung wiegt mehr als 30 kg man
muss Rennen man muss schießen natürlich
verstehe ich warum die Ukrainer Rennen
schießen und ihr Land schützen aber
warum die Russen das ganze die ganze
Idee dahinter ist so
idiotisch völlig sinnlos was der
russische Führer
davon ein ist auf der Insel aufgewachsen
bei ihm spüre ich die Tiefe Verachtung
für den einstigen Besatzer Russland
besonders
[Musik]
stark frei auf dem Meer fahren die
Fischer können den Fisch fangen wir
können Segeln ohne Beschränkungen durch
irgendwelche idiotischen Regeln oder
idiotischen Ideen die sich nie erfüllt
haben warum sollten wir so etwas
befolgen auch in der estnischen
Hauptstadt haben sie sowjetmonumente aus
dem öffentlichen Leben Verband Tallin
die Kuhle an der Ostsee mittelalterliche
Innenstadt aber Talin ist auch jung am
Strand lernen wir Matthias kennen mich
interessiert ob er seine Freunde jemals
darüber nachgedacht haben zu gehen
Russland ist
Nachbar wir haben das unter uns Freunden
besprochen weil immer die Frage im Raum
steht ob Russland in die baltischen
Staaten kommt unds wieder
überfällt die meisten von uns würden
nicht
weglaufen wir wären bereit mit der Waffe
in der Hand an die Front zu gehen den
Feind zu bekämpfen und die Heimat zu
verteidigen
Matthias ist 22 hat längst sein eigenes
Startup eine Ehrensache in Tallin
Matthias entwickelt onlinepiele als
Werbeplattformen er könnte in London
oder Shanghai arbeiten aber er
bleibt jedes Mal wenn ich einen Monat
oder länger weg war habe ich gefühlt ich
vermisse etwas von
Estland was auch immer wir sagen über
unser Land es ist unser Zuhause und wir
lieben es
voll digital unterwegs analog zum
Sängerfest einst haben sich die drei
baltischen Länder mit Singen gegen die
Sowjets gestellt mit der singenden
Revolution gegen russische
Panzer das ist ein Sängerfest eine Party
bringt uns zusammen und bedeutet jedem
einzelnen enen sehr viel ein Muss im
Sommer
das hier ist keine spießige Folklore es
ist die Identität einer oft
fremdbestimmten kleineen Nation
Generationen sollten damals statt ihrer
esnischen Lieder die sowjetideologie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
feiern
mein Großvater war schon kursänger meine
Mutter hat getanzt und ich bin schon
seit 18 Jahren im Kur es ist Teil der
esnischen Kultur
einkudier der wichtigste Tag im talliner
Sommer und dann
das auch das gehört zur Ostsee das
Wetter schlägt schlagartig
um wir sind jetzt klch aber das dämpft
doch nicht unseren Spirit wir sind
trotzdem auf der Bühne und singen unser
Lied singen hört nie
[Musik]
auf die Esten ein kleines 1,3 Millionen
Volk an der Ostsee im Machtpoker der
Jahrhunderte oft fremd
bestimmt wir reisen nach
n hier wohnen die die früher ihr
Weltbild den Esten aufzwangen Narva ist
bis heute die russischste Stadt
Estlands nur ein Fluss trennt hier beide
Länder das Lebensgefühl in der Stadt ist
immer noch russisch die Vorfahren zu
Sowjetzeiten einst bewusst von Moskau
hier
[Musik]
angesiedelt wir sind auf dem Grenzfluss
zu Russland unterwegs wir auf esnischer
Seite drüben
Russland auch die Familie von
Touristenführer Andrej stammt aus
Russland ich fühle mich als Russe aber
ich lebe in Estland schon 38 Jahre und
liebe dieses Land hier habe ich mein
ganzes Leben
verbracht Andrei spricht kein istnisch
wie die meisten die in der istnischen
Grenzstadt Nava leben ein waren die
Russen die bestimmer in Estland heute
sind sie nur noch die Minderheit viele
bewundern den starken Mann in Moskau und
trauern der Vergangenheit nach wie
Taxifahrer
Andrei es hat 30 Jahre leben im
Kapitalismus gedauert um zu verstehen
dass es in der Sowjetunion besser
war ausgerechnet von hier aus ging ein
Video von Alina in den sozialen
Netzwerken viral mit Protest gegen Putin
mit Putin ist ein Wicher
ich habe mich mit Alina am Grenzfluss
verabredet auch sie hat russische
Wurzeln es war verboten irgendwelche
Poster mitzubringen weil sie die
Situation ruhig halten wollten es ist
wirklich sehr gefährlich wenn sich die
Leute hier in Estland untereinander
streiten und so war alles was Russland
oder die Ukraine unterstützt verboten
aber du kannst ja nicht einfach jemanden
ein T-Shirt ausziehen
richtig
während wir drehen regt sich hinter der
Kamera eine Passantin auf man solle die
Polizei wegen dieser antiputin
Propaganda rufen doch vor der Kamera
verstummt sie und verschwindet die
russische Seite beschalte im Mai von
drüben die estnische mit einem Konzert
und kremmelpropaganda die in Estland
gehört werden sollte viele der
Nachkommen der in Narva angesiedelten
Russen verfolgen nur russische Medien
[Musik]
ich war einfach sehr
verergert weiß du sie machen da drüben
ein Konzert extra für uns auf unserer
Seite für unsere esnische Seite das ist
pure
Provokation es gibt dort dieses narrativ
dass die Leute hier bei uns im Grunde
eingeschränkt
sind für Touristen ist die Grenze zu wer
Familie hat auf beiden Seiten darf hin
und her offen über den Krieg in der
Ukraine sprechen eigentlich ein Tabu in
Nava Alina tut es
trotzdem natürlich hoffe ich dass die
Ukraine
gewinnt aber gleichzeitig bin ich
besorgt was nach Putin kommt wer wird
das
sein die letzten Nachrichten zu
prin war wie eine große Revolution sah
es aus aber gleichzeitig wolltest du
prigin an der Macht
sehen auch wenn man spürt dass hier viel
russischer Geist weht wir sind immer
noch in
Estland Alina nimmt uns mit in ihre Welt
sie ist Lehrerin nach dem Protest gegen
Putin legte ihr die Schulleitung nah zu
kündigen die 22jährige fühlt sich als
Estin Punkt sie mir dieses russische
trauern um die Vergangenheit zu
erklären manchmal denke ich mir
vielleicht war das Leben für sie früher
einfacher du hattest eine Ideologie
einen Job ein Haus die gleichen Freunde
aber jetzt ist alles fragil und unsicher
und du hast so viel Auswahl du musst so
viel Wissen und kritisch denken das ist
nicht mir so
leicht seit
1991 ist Estland wieder
unabhängig es gehen Risse durch Familien
auch durch die von
Alina ich sehe mich als ist und ich
liebe meinen Vater klar wir haben
unterschiedliche politische Ansichten
wir haben verschiedene Meinungen zu
Identität ich glaube das regt vor allem
ihn auf und meine Mama sagt mirch g aber
wir haben trotzdem eine gute
Beziehung also ist er pro
Putin kein Problem für
dich wir haben hitzige Debatten manchmal
aber weißt du wann wir uns einig sein
werden wird die Zeit zeigen die Zeit
wird das sicherlich
zeigen
Musiklehrerin Alina schreibt ihre
Gefühle in
[Musik]
Lieder sie wird Nava nach dem Sommer
verlassen nicht mehr ihre Welt sie geht
in die Hauptstadt
[Musik]
Tallin zurück in ein ganz anderes
Lebensgefühl nach hiuma der Insel ganz
im Westen Estlands früher für Besucher
gesperrt heute ein Hipster Hotspot
wir treffen Britt und katlin die
Freundinnen kommen aus der Hauptstadt
Tallin sind aber im Herzen echte Huma
Mädels immer am Wasser meist mit
irgendeinem
Brett der Wind will heute nicht surfen
fällt
aus sehr schade dass heute nicht der
richtige Tag ist aber diese Welle kann
wann auch immer auftauchen hier an der
Ostsee wissen wir es nie im Voraus es
gibt keine Strömung man muss einfach
präsent
sein schaut euch doch das hier an sogar
wenn es keine Welle gibt schaut einfach
in mein Gesicht es ist trotzdem einfach
toll
fantastisch in Estland heißt die Ostsee
Westsee warum habe ich sie gefragt ihre
Antwort guck doch auf die Landkarte
stimmt natürlich das Meer im Westen des
Landes BR und K sind im Film und Event
be verbringen den Sommer
hier sie sind 39 und 42 waren Kinder als
die Sowjetunion zerfiel doch ihre
Familien kennen Russland noch als
Besatzer ihres Landes jetzt der
russische Krieg gegen die Ukraine es
macht sie
nachdenklich man beginnt auch die
eigenen Eltern besser zu verstehen die
ja unter dem russischen Joch gelebt
haben und warum die Esten so sind in
ihrem Wesen wie viel äußere Einmischung
wir hatten in der Vergangenheit in
unsere
Identität
die Freiheit die wir seit 30 Jahren
haben erscheint für die jungen Leute so
selbstverständlich aber das kann man
ihnen nicht
vorwerfen für viele im Baltikum steht
fest dass Putin sie eigentlich wieder
haben will die natoitgliedschaft
beruhigt dennoch haben zuletzt viele
Esten Wohnungen im Ausland gekauft viele
weit weg im Westen wie in
Spanien trotz der Spannungen ihre meiste
Zeit ist
[Musik]
unbeschwert an den Krieg hat man sich
irgendwie
gewöhnt die Leichtigkeit auf hum wird
besonders deutlich an Tagen wie diesem
die
Sonnenwende es ist das Highlight des
Jahres auf der Insel auf mich machen die
beiden den Eindruck das Leben in Estland
ist für sie fast
alternativl
dieser magische Ort kalana hat uns hier
auf hiuma
verankert es wäre nicht allzu
kompliziert mit unseren Familien ins
Ausland zu
gehen aber vorstellen kann ich es mir
eigentlich
nicht dass ich Freunde und Familie
verlassen müsste das ist nicht so
leicht aber der Gedanke war natürlich da
besonders intensiv in den ersten Tagen
na dem 24
Februar
KAS me sa niö mit familtenen plan b b
Ikki Oli n s sutes
olemas weltoffen aber immer sehr
heimatverbunden so erlebe ich die Esten
seit Jahren weil ihre Heimat ihnen immer
wieder gestohlen
[Musik]
wurde von Estland reisen wir weiter nach
Lettland unwegs im glamurösesten Seebad
Lettlands bis Kriegsbeginn noch Hotspot
für reiche Russen
Jurmala eins nach soi und Jalta der
Badeort in der Sowjetunion der lettische
Spitzenkoch Lauris hat schon für
Oligarchen
gekocht früher traten sämtliche
russischen Popgrößen in Jurmala auf aber
lettland hat die Grenze zu Russland
geschlossen
[Musik]
es sind einfach viele Festivals
gecancelt worden die für und von Russen
veranstaltet wurden so
einfach aber wir sind noch da und das
ist
gut und der
Rest Lauris hat Umsatz einbßen die
Russen haben es gerne krachen lassen
trotzdem kann er die Sanktionen gegen
Russland
nachvollziehen ist doch das gleiche wie
in Deutschland wenn deutsche Unternehmen
viele Deals mit Russland hatten und du
fragst sie ob sie das jetzt vermissen
vom Geld her das vermisst du vielleicht
aber wenn du von der anderen Seite drauf
schaust dann vermisst du das
nicht weggehen woanders Kochen keine
Option für ihn nur ein paar Meter weg
vom ur
[Musik]
aufwach hier ist einfach die Energie
fürs Kochen wunderschön weil die ganze
Zeit jeden Tag jede Minute die wir
arbeiten sehen wir diese wunderschöne
Landschaft das
hilft Geschäftsmann aber auch durch und
durch Lette das ist mir klar geworden
für die Letten ist Russland der machung
Feind mehr den
je ich bin stolz auf unsere Sprache weil
nur 1,5 Millionen Menschen sprechen
diese Sprache vielleicht sogar weniger
es ist ein Erbe wir müssen unsere
Sprache bewahren sehr
sogar
erst covid und nun ist es nicht leichter
für ihn geworden ohne die russische
Kundschaft die er im Grunde seines
lettischen Herzens nicht vermisst
wir verlassen das noble Jurmala in eine
andere lettische Realität an der
[Musik]
Ostsee Russlands Machtanspruch bestimmt
auch hier das Leben der
Menschen der alte Kriegshafen von
carosta mit seinem ausgedienten
Militärgefängnis für für sowjetische
Marinesoldaten auch heute kann man sich
hier anschreien lassen wenn man dafür
zahlt ich habe noch was interessantem
gesucht und da fiel mir das vor die Füße
und da sind
wir mein Mann hat mir das zum Geburtstag
geschenkt romantisches
Wochenende Gita und Jannis sind aus der
Nähe von Riga Antreten zur Extremtour ab
50 € alles aufsammeln alles
alle werden bestraft wenn einer ein
Idiot ist wie gerade
Thomas einmal sich fühlen wie ein
straffählliger sowjetmatrose
damals kannst du jetzt
atmen
jetzt siehst du es
funktioniert Einchecken im militärknast
Gehorsam Oberst das Gebot die Truppe ist
sofort tief drin im Spiel wie Jannis ist
okay
interessant die Geschichten die er uns
erzählt hat das hat mich echt
nachdenklich gemacht über unsere dunklen
Zeiten der
Geschichte keine Fragen angespannte
Stimmung nicht zerstören klare Ansage an
mich nach einer Stunde traue ich mich
vorsichtig wozu das Ganze um Himmels
willen
es ist jetzt anders solche Fragen zu
beantworten denn seit letztem Jahr seit
Februar
2022 haben viele Kollegen ihre Uniform
geändert von sowjetisch zu
neutral weil wir mit beiden Regimen
Russisch und sowjetisch nichts zu tun
haben wollen in diesen Tagen schon gar
nicht
glorifizieren aber die Geschichte
zeigen das kann man sich doch viel
besser merken mit so einer Erfahrung
hier
die sowjetischen Zeiten hier das war
ziemlich genau das was gerade in der
Ukraine
passiert wir verstehen sie wir helfen
Ihnen so gut es
geht D Stunden Drill Bleis schwere
Munition transportieren die Zeit zieht
sich man leidet
mit
das war eine echt interessante Übung wir
mussten diese Granate tragen die ist
extrem schwer so etwa 40
kg das war bestimmt Absicht nur zwei von
uns haben das geschafft da habe ich
gefühlt es wurde mir klar wie schwierig
das für die Soldaten in der Ukraine ist
ihr Land zu
verteidigen extrem
schwierig die Drangsalierung geht weiter
eigentlich bin ich nur Beobachterin doch
dann die Anweisung an mich rann an die
Wand ich tue es komme da nicht raus
funktioniere ein wirklich merkwürdiges
Gefühl der nächste Morgen es ist vorbei
die Nacht auf dem Holzbrett wirkt
spürbar
nach wie war die
Nacht das war jetzt nicht wie im Hotel
keine frische Luft Schimmel überall und
dann diese Art Bett aber ich habe es
geschafft war ist das
wert definitiv ich kann es jeden nur
empfehlen wir alle haben
Angst das ist ein kollektives Trauma für
alle postsjetst
und tief in uns drinnen haben wir Angst
dass das noch mal passieren
könnte muss man so etwas wirklich
gemacht haben ist das schräg zynisch
oder eben gerade nicht weil es hilft die
aktuelle Lage besser zu verstehen eine
Antwort finde ich so schnell nicht was
ich aber mitnehme die Bedrohung durch
den alten Besatz ist durchaus wieder ein
Thema in
Lettland wir reisen weiter nach Riga und
wollen verstehen wie groß heute noch die
Befindlichkeiten zwischen den einst
angesiedelten Russen und den Letten
sind der berühmte Markt der lettischen
Hauptstadt mit seinen
Markthallen wir treffen Reinhard krumm
Leiter der Friedrich Ebert Stiftung in
den baltischen en er war Anfang der 90er
Jahre als Journalist in Moskau später
der erste DP Korrespondent in Lettland
er spricht russisch viele hier verstehen
ihn ich komme hier gerne hin weil ich
früher ja Journalist war und hier ohne
dass ich das immer gemacht habe oder so
häufig gemacht habe hier können sie
Geschichten einfangen weil
Lettland die Menschen haben so viel
unterschiedliche mchte in dann gehabt
und da sind so viele Widersprüche und
die kriegen sie hier zu hören was
bedeutet das ist das auch so ein
bisschen das lettischrussische
Verhältnis oder auch auch ja wie geht
man mit Russland um mag man Russland
nicht aber sie haben natürlich ja auch
eine große Anzahl von russischsprachiger
Bevölkerung der Minderheit hier wird
russisch gesprochen hier wird lettisch
gesprochen damals kein
Englisch viele Produkte fehlen weil
durch die Sanktionen für Russland die
Lieferung in die EU versperrt ist
stattdessen findet man verstärkt
Produkte aus dem Westen und
Nordafrika es ist nicht leicht mit
russischstämmigen Menschen über Politik
zu sprechen und den Krieg in der
Ukraine viele trauen sich nicht offen
ihre Meinung zu sagen z.B wenn sie für
die Unterstützung der Ukraine
[Musik]
sind interess dazu die
die Menschen abgefragt haben das war
eine repräsentative Umfrage es gibt
schon eine Menge auch der
russischprachigen Minderheit die das
unterstützt aber es gibt in Gesprächen
in der Familie das haben wir abgefragt
eben auch eine ganze Menge von von den
Menschen die es weiterhin mit Russland
halten die lettische Regierung hat nun
vor dem Hintergrund des russischen
angriffskriegs in der Ukraine die Regeln
geändert für die zu Sowjetzeiten hier
angesiedelten Russen Russisch als sprach
in der Schule soll verschwinden aus
Prinzip die Leute müssen einen
lettischtest absolvieren wer durchfällt
soll perspektivisch das Land verlassen
müssen und manche leben schon seit
vielen Jahrzehnten
hier fehlt dann den len Identität
eigentlich eine
gemeinsame das ist eine exzellente Frage
für nicht wenige Politiker für ser
konservative Politiker ist
Lettland das Land der Letten Letten
und die russische sprachige Minderheit
ist ihn aufgedrängt worden was zum Teil
auch richtig ist die drei baltischen
Staaten nach der Okkupierung durch die
Sowjetunion da ist ein ordentlicher
Zuzug gewesen aber es ist halt Teil des
Landes jetzt und die Hoffnung ist glaube
ich dass gerade die älteren Menschen
dann irgendwann
halt
aussterben und bei den Jüngeren das
haben auch die Umfragen ergeben ist das
Verhältnis zu Lettland zu Europa
deutlich
in der Markthalle zwischen den
traditionellen Rig Sprotten viel
Räucherfisch
Gewürze ein russischsprachiger
gewürzehändler spricht Reinhard krumm an
er beschwert sich über die Sanktionen
gegen
Russland die Geschäfte laufen
normalin ser gut es gibt kein Geschäft
das Geschäft ist am
absterben wegen der
Importbeschränkungen ja für mich ist die
Hälfte weggebrochen natürlich es ist
nicht erlaubt etwas einzuführen wären
wir in Russland hätten wir
Geld rieer die lettische Hauptstadt im
Spannungsfeld zwischen dem Geist des
einstigen Besatzers Moskau und den
stolzen Letten die ihre Identität
verteidigen in der russischen
Gemeinschaft hängt manch ein al Zeiten
nach und ausgerechnet riga ist zum Exil
für viele Russen aus Russland geworden
die sich zu Hause nicht mehr sicher
fühlten so wie Jelena russische
Journalistin sie ist nach Riga
[Musik]
geflohen wir haben vor dem Krieg
Praktiker im Ausland absolviert und wir
haben früher Publikationen
veröffentlicht die von internationalen
journalistischen Fonds finanziert wurden
deshalb hätten wir als ausländische
Agenten gelten
können und natürlich unterstützen wir
nicht den
Krieg am Wochenende treffen sich Helena
und andere russische exiljournalisten zu
Entspannungsübungen an der
Ostsee anders als helelena meiden viele
unsere Kamera aus Sorge vor dem
langenarm
Moskaus
[Musik]
als mein Land in die Ukraine
einmarschierte hielt ich es für
unethisch in meiner Heimat zu bleiben
weil ich die Politik der Regierung nicht
unterstütze und keine Möglichkeit fand
erfolgreich zu
protestieren deshalb bin ich mit meiner
Familie
gegangenena schreibt für eine lettische
russischprachige Zeitung eine Rückkehr
in ihr altes Leben zu riskant und obwohl
die Ostsee sie an zuause erinnert sie
vermisst stankt
petersburg auf jeden Fall will ich meine
Mutter besuchen meine Verwandten sehen
ich hoffe wirklich dass das bald vorbei
ist auch wenn das niemand mit Sicherheit
sagen
kann Zufluchtsort riger wir treffen die
Schauspielerin tulpan kamatova in
Deutschland bekannt aus dem Film goodbye
Lenin sie war im Ausland als ihr Land
die Ukraine überfiel und kehrte nicht
mehr nach Russland zurück holte auch die
Töchter von Moskau nach Riga
nach ich habe meine Zukunft
verloren alle Pläne als Schauspielerin
alle Pläne für Wohltätigkeit sind
innerhalb eines Tages
verschwunden sie kritisiert den
russischen Imperialismus sie sagt uns
sie könne nicht still sein würde am
liebsten ihre Meinung laut in Moskau
sagen lebensgefährlich bei einer Person
des öffentlichen Lebens in Riga ist das
möglich das ist Selbstmord für
Russland weil es jetzt keine Zukunft
mehr
gibt Putin und seine Freunde haben die
Zukunft des Landes
WE ist nur wenige Flugstunden von
entfernt die Nähe ihre Popularität
machen sie zur möglichen
Zielscheibe zurück auf dem Stützpunkt
der Sowjets an der Ostsee in Lettland
der alte Wasserturm des
militärhafens die alte Funktion ist
vorbei hier arbeiten nun Künstler wie
der Lette Egons
Egons war erst neun als Lettland
unabhängig wurde von der
Sowjetunion
[Musik]
wenn ich auf die Sowjetunion Blicke ist
sie
langweilig und
grau so sehe ich die
Sowjetunion heute wird alles
farbenfroher interessanter diverser
offener Freiheit ist für mich das
Wichtigste das war etwas das in
Sowjetzeiten eben nicht da
[Musik]
war
zeitgenössische lettische Kunst mitten
in einem Viertel das früher gesperrt war
nur Angehörige der Militärs durften rein
heute leben noch viele der von Moskau
hier angesiedelten russischen Familien
Egons will hier mittendrin mit seiner
Kunst die Kulturen in Kontakt bringen
verbinden und doch spüre ich für wen
sein letisches Herz schlägt in
[Musik]
Kriegszeiten ihnen vor allem mit den
Ukrainern sie leiden immer noch am
meisten wir sind der Sowjetunion
entkommen ziemlich
schnell der Turm war strategisch wichtig
für die Wasserversorgung von cararosta
in Sowjetzeiten heute Kunst damals
scharf bewacht
Egons zeigt mir wo sich Matrosen in der
Wand
verewigten das hier ist von
85 es gibt auch ältere siehst du von
56 ist es wichtig diese Dinge zu
bewahren ich weiß es nicht so ist das
Leben Dinge erscheinen Dinge
verschwinden F Jahrzehnte
Sowjetherrschaft in
Lettland mai
1950 hier war eine Wachstation Leute
haben einfach was eingeritzt wenn sie
hier zu Tode gelangweilt
waren
vor allem jüngere Letten sowie Egons
arbeiten nun bewusst auf dem
exmilitärgelände bringen neues
Leben in litaauen fahren wir entlang der
Kurischen Nährung direkt an der Grenze
zu Kaliningrad eine Halbinsel mit
Bilderbuchlandschaft ein Teil gehört zu
Litauen der andere zu Russland am Steuer
soteras hier aufgewachsen er hat schon
als Kind Deutsch gelernt wegen der
Touristen Russland den früheren Besatzer
hat er immer im Blick Putin hat den
Verlust der baltischen Republiken nie
verschmerzt wenn die kommen die kommen
was kann ich machen ich kann nur alles
mitpacken und z.B nach Deutschland
fahren weil ich kann besser deutsch als
Englisch das
war's ja soteras bietet Bootstouren an
er hat sich fürs verdrängen entschieden
so mein Eindruck meidet
Nachrichten mit diese ganze NS will ich
gar nicht so viel hören ne ich will nur
hören wenn die Ukraine gewinnt dann dann
gucke ich wieder nü aber
jetzt viele auf der Nährung sprechen
deutsch wegen der Touristen die gesamte
Familie von zoteras lebt vom Tourismus
er lädt uns nach Hause ein in das Hotel
sein Familie wir sprechen über das Leben
dicht an
Russland die die Angst haben wollten
sind schon weg haben irgendwo in Spanien
ein Haus gekauft oder Wohnung gekauft
oder Job verlassen und weggegangen und
alle andere wohnen wie
[Musik]
vorher die Halbinsel kurische Nährung
zwischen Ostsee und kurischem HA ein
Sehnsuchtsort der größten Dünen Europas
und Kiefernwälder ich bin mit auschra
Feser verabredet der Chefin im
Nationalpark mit einem Deutschen
verheiratet Putins Einmarsch in die
Ukraine hat viel verändert viele
Touristen stornierten im vergangenen
Jahr langsam kommen sie wieder
zurück deutsche Gäste und fragen sie uns
ist Russland nah sagt ja nah sehr nah na
sehr nah und haben Sie Termine von der
fre wir müssen wissen wenn irgendwas
passiert dit wir schnell weggehen mit
der
fre durch die Halbinsel verläuft die
Grenze zum russischen Kaliningrad auf
dem Festland
hochmitarisiert Moskau hat auch Iskander
Raketen stationiert Reichweite bis nach
[Musik]
Berlin ganz hinten neue Türme im
idül Türmen Nerven richtig weil hier
Landschaft ist natürlich das Wichtigste
kommen so viele Menschen und die sind
total Fremdkörper hier und natürlich man
weiß genau das ist Zweck ist ist Militär
und nicht irgendwie Verbindung oder
irgendwie vor dem 24 Februar arbeitete
die geographin mit der russischen Seite
an einem gemeinsamen
Reiseführer doch danach hat sie jede
Form von Kontakt abgebrochen
schlagartig das war so starkes Gefühl
dass mit mit mit diesen Nation mit
diesen Menschen wollen wir nichts mehr
zu tun haben das war so ein Schmerz das
war ein richtigge Schmerz und und und
Gefühl dass man kann nicht mehr mit
denen sprechen man kann nicht mehr in
die Augen sehen du hast kein Thema mehr
weil das Thema ist Krieg Ukraine diese
Themen was wir hatten die sind nicht
mehr wichtig die Nährung ein
litaauisches bullabü wäre da nicht der
unberechenbare Nachbar erst seit 1990
ist Litauen von Moskau
unabhängig auf dem Festland liegt die
Stadt
kleipeda beschaulich mit einem
malerischen Bootshafen und
Altstadt aber kleipeda ist auch
strategisch Bedeut
l hier ist der wichtigste Frachthafen
des Landes dort gibt es auch ein LNG
Terminal ist die handelschefin des
Terminals sie nimmt uns dahin mit die
Drehgenehmigung hat gedauert kritische
Infrastruktur die in diesen Zeiten noch
schärfer geschützt wird z.B ist die
Marine hier verstärkt im
Einsatz der Krieg haben vieleusätzliche
sicherheen Z werden LNG
schiffslieferungen
eskortiert man hat also diesen Nachbarn
der groß ist und manchmal Energie macht
politisch nutzt gegen
Nachbarländer litauen hat er schon
früher Erfahrung gemacht mit solchen
Situationen Cyberangriff auf Ihre Firma
habe es längst gegeben sagt mir Jita das
LNG Terminal seit 2014 in Betrieb
independence der Name ist Programm davor
war Litauen abhängig von russischem Gas
misstraute Moskau aber früh und setzte
stattdessen auf internationales LNG
litaauen warnte stets vor der
Abhängigkeit von russischem Gas war
scharfer Kritiker von nordstream 2 und
damit vom deutschen
weg an Russland trotz des Fakts dass wir
nicht eine sehr lange Grenze mit
Russland haben aber wir haben die Grenze
zur esklave Kaliningrad und auch die
Grenze zu Belarus das sehr eng mit
Russland verbunden ist so vor allem
gerade
jetzt für uns in der Nachbarschaft
dieser Länder bringt es die Grenze zur
Ukraine sehr nah auch zu unseren
Grenzen
Russland auf der einen Seite westliche
Partner auf der anderen die Ausrichtung
litaunens ist klar Jita spricht für das
LNG Terminal aber die große Mehrheit in
litaauen teilt ihre
Meinung der erste Eindruck ist dass wir
die Ostsee mit allen Ländern drumherum
Teilen etwas was uns vereint für
Kooperationen z.B
und jetzt mit Finnland in der NATO sind
fast alle ostseestaaten in der
NATO gegen die gemeinsame Bedrohung
direkt an der
Grenze im Bootshafen von klepeda kommen
gerade fischergis und seine Jungs von
der Ostsee zurück die russischen ete
immer vor der
[Musik]
Nase seit dem Krieg ist es hier nicht
mehr so ruhig beide Seiten überwachen
Ihre Grenzen schärfer die litauische
Marine begegnet ihnen jetzt
öfters wir können die Anspannung sehen
die Drohnen die da
fliegen Drohnen Flugzeuge Helikopter
mehr Schiffe wir sehen da echt viel
davon ich hab gar nichtsst Ukrainer die
Russen schlagen können dann könnten wir
das auch lass sie nur kommen alles wird
gut kämpfen für die Heimat sagen Sie mir
aber klar doch jederzeit die Fischerei
ein Knochenjob aber ihr
Lebenselixier die Ostsee ist einfach
mein zuause ich bin hier aufgewachsen
ich arbeite schon 30 Jahre hier jetzt
fängt auch mein Sohn hier an es bedeutet
mir alles wir sind ein maritimes Land
für die Leute in kaipeda bedeutet die
See alles
virgis und seine Jungs laden uns in ihre
Fischhalle ein sie sind stolz auf den
Job und ihr litaauen Sohn Paulus wird im
Fall der Fälle der Heimatarmee beitreten
die boomt in litaauen mit nicht nur bei
waffennachen bei Vater WIRIS spürt man
jeder balte trägt seine
Familiengeschichte und die Erfahrung mit
Moskau im
Herzen
meineoelterdeniriench wurden wo anders
hingebracht vielleicht auch getötet
weißt du wo immer die Russen auftauchen
haben sie nichts Gutes hinterlassen
meine gesamte Familie wurde deportiert
also die Ukrainer machen gerade ihren
Job für uns alle nicht nur für sich so
denke ich
einfach paulus hat einen
ingenieurabschluss Zeitverschwendung
nennt er es er will an und auf der
Ostsee arbeiten diead waren das Land die
Werte
verteidigen und die Freiheit an ihrer
Ostsee nicht noch einmal verlieren das
eint die Menschen im
[Musik]
Baltikum